look can I take my jacket off go ahead
go ahead oh my god um I've never eaten
anything so spicy in my life
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we open up season eleven with
Margot Robbie she has a pair of Academy
Award nominations and a list of
highlights and includes wolf of
wallstreet i Tanya bombshell Suicide
Squad among many many others her latest
film birds of prey is set to theatres on
February 7th Margot Robbie welcome to
the show thanks for having me what's
your headspace like going into this I'm
so scared I have the palette of a four
year old and grew up eating mashed
potato
so my tolerance for spicy food is
extremely limited
[Music]
[Applause]
haha okay it's very nice of you to do
this with me by the way thank you I
think it's only fair I meet you halfway
on this you know hmm I can do that
I find that very spicy actually I'm not
kidding kind of find that spider thing
well we're in for it today so the last
Suicide Squad movie I understand that
you had to learn how to hold your breath
underwater for five minutes
mm-hmm do you have to learn how to do
anything similarly daunting for this
role in birds of prey hmm I spent a lot
of the movie on rollerskates we actually
have a big scene on a moving carousel
and then I'm behind a car and like it's
just really hard to do all that on
wheels so that was very actually very
challenging but ya know the holding my
breath thing that's like a fun party
trick now it's just a nice thing to be
able to say like yeah I can hold my
breath for five minutes just like a free
diver teach you how to do that you would
be able to do it too a few Travie to him
yeah if you like sat with him he would
he would just yeah because he teaches
you you know how to take a big breath
and expand your diaphragm and all that
kind of stuff really the most important
thing he teaches you is what happens
when your body's deprived of oxygen and
then once you know it's not that scary
when it starts happening so it's like so
you'll have compulsions when you start
getting to this point and then you've
got another like 30 40 seconds after
that so just ride out the convulsions
then they'll get worse and then like
this will happen and then like when you
come up you go to purge you heard your
body of carbon monoxide and some people
might pass out like this and look like
this but you'll be fine so once you know
all that when you're like underwater and
you're you know three-and-a-half minutes
or something and you start having
convulsions you're like okay I'm gonna
ride this out for another minute like
it's just nice to know
hmm Oh yummy don't splash him
and manageable oh yeah that's definitely
spicy I'm cool then yeah we're getting
towards like the threshold of what I've
ever eaten before um I was actually just
in Sri Lanka and so I feel like I did
broaden my horizons as far as spice and
curries but this is a real yeah
and we're on number two I'm scared so as
someone with over a hundred thousand
unread work emails I find it very
impressive that you're able to wear
multiple hats is not only the lead star
but also a producer on films like I
Tanya and birds of prey what's a more
nerve-wracking part of the filmmaking
experience for a producer is it getting
talent on board or watching the first
week box office numbers rolling mmm can
I start drinking more than of course and
no time living on that my lips are
burning already um the most odd the most
most nerve-wracking probably the box
office because at that point you can't
do anything anymore you've kind of like
I mean you can kind of pivot your
marketing strategy a little bit but
really there's not a lot you can do and
you just hope that people like it and
you and so many people have spent so
much time on something that you just
want people to like it or even see it
[Music]
hotter again has anyone ever been this
pathetic at number three you know I mean
I can't tell I can tell that you have a
sensitive palate Margaux but it's not
just my mouth as my lips that I like but
I think that the measure of it all is
like can you keep it going yeah
definitely what it is as as weak as I am
with spice tolerance I am strong and
repetitiveness determination associate
so CK and I'm gonna save the milk to
later to like I'm really desperate
strategic got smashed rata G so before
your career in foam I know that you
worked as a sandwich artists at Subway
I did what do you think was one of the
more bizarre sandwiches that you ever
made from behind the counter hmm
probably the ones I made for myself
because I wanted to try every different
variation I think I was really good at
it though because I you know would
really spread everything out to the
edges evenly the right amount of every
ticket seriously yeah and now when I go
to Subway and someone just kind of like
throws it on right in the middle like it
puts a ton of sauce there like I just it
kills me like I actually don't go that
often anymore because I watch them make
it badly and I'm upset do you share
Harley Quinn's obsession with egg
sandwiches I'm allergic to chicken egg
whites so I love egg sandwiches but they
gave me migraines about you so when we
did the scene they actually had to make
them with duck eggs and it's very
delicious
but yes I do love egg sandwiches when I
can eat them and finally is it true that
you once crushed four pounds of pasta to
win a bolognaise eating competition oh
my god you really done you reset yes I
yes I once ate four pounds of spaghetti
bolognaise in an hour that was the
that's very first a time frame yeah that
made it more difficult otherwise I don't
know how much I could have eaten
probably not that much more cuz I was
some I was really sick it was it was a
lot of spaghetti it was like a bucket of
spaghetti but you won but I won I won by
like 300 grams or something I can't
remember what exactly but it was
a really important moment in my life
I'll never forget
[Music]
everything like the mushroom flavor but
the scotch bonnet it's really really hot
okay we've now hit the stage where this
is uncharted territory uncharted
territory I think this is the hardest
thing I've ever eaten
am I allowed to hold her in my mouth
sure a minute well especially for this
one because we have a nice long wind-up
on this one Margo mm-hmm so as we've
touched on your deeply involved in this
film I know that it's your baby and it
was important to you to give Harley
Quinn a girl squad well guess what in
anticipation of this interview we have
reached out to some of your co-stars to
get the inside baseball on birds of prey
directly from the source so here they
are the birds up first we have jurnee
smollett Belle with a question for Margo
Margo for me the most challenging thing
about shooting birds of prey and playing
Black Canary was obviously the stunts
those kicks kicked my ass what's the
most challenging part for you and
playing Harley now a star on fire
I can barely concentrate the most
challenging part of playing holi was
[Applause]
maybe the Sun stuff was really hard I
mean we had to have to have milk now I
go for so far all right up next okay we
have mary elizabeth winstead and she has
a question for you Margo hey Margo so
I've heard that you're kind of obsessed
with tattoos so out of all of Harley's
many tattoos do you have a favorite and
why haven't you given me a tattoo yet
that's a very good question I actually
do have a favorite tattoo so I'm you
don't really you don't see it in this
movie because we're the costumes life
but in Suicide Squad one you could
probably see like a little peek of it
but on her right hip she has a dolphin
jumping over a rainbow and I love that
tattoo because I thought that to howleen
Quinzel getting a tattoo would have
seemed super rebellious and she had no
idea obviously with her life the bleed
and at like 15 she probably thought like
the most rebellious hardcore but cool
tattoo was this dolphin jumping over a
rainbow right there on the hip because
that would be kind of sexy and that just
seemed like something that
fifteen-year-old Colleen Quinzel would
do so that was always my favorite
because it felt like there was a bit of
a history with it all right we have one
more for you Ella J hey Margo one of my
favorite things about Cassandra Cain was
decorating her cast so I have a question
for you if you were Harley what would
you draw on her cast oh I would
I would what number we up to your by the
way we're almost halfway next we're at
the halfway mark okay um I would
probably I mean if I was Holly and I was
drawing on Cassandra Kane's cost
I'd probably write a whole bunch of rude
words and probably draw a bunch of dicks
Oh something inappropriate to put on a
child's cost cuz Holly's not always very
appropriate all right Margo I know
[Music]
which one is this one the las calientes
Rojo halfway mark already like halfway
and you know what Margo here at the
halfway mark we do this recurring
segment called explain that grande where
you do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram so we'll pop the picture you
just tell us the bigger story that's me
right now I'm trying to eat these wings
do you remember the internal dialogue
here it looks like you're suffering I
mean I'm guessing the ranges weren't
doing well at that particular point in
time I'm guessing the other team
probably just scored or got past us and
you played a right wing for like an
amateur hockey team when you move to the
other dude yeah I didn't know how to ice
skate at that point because there's not
there's no ice in Australia so I mean
there is but there wasn't where I grew
up and I always wanted to play ice
hockey because I loved the Mighty Ducks
when I was little and I couldn't go play
ice hockey because it was like an hour
away and I was on Saturdays my mom
worked on Saturdays and so I played
field hockey at school and then when I
got to America I was like I'm in America
I can play ice hockey now so I was good
at the hockey but not so good at the
skating like I could go fast but I
didn't know how to stop
so I'd either just like hit someone will
fall over smash into the wall so I would
say I was a below average player but the
team that's very kind to me that's nice
all right yeah next here you are I think
this is the LA premiere hmm what was it
like to sit next to Tonya at the Golden
Globes it was really fun and um she was
obviously so excited to be there and I
was excited to be there but she just was
not afraid to go up to anyone at all
whereas I was like oh my gosh there's
so-and-so they're amazing I don't I
don't want to both of them should be I'm
gonna go say hi to Tom Hanks oh no the
side door and she would not be often
just having a chat with them and
everyone loved it everyone was really
excited that she was there it was busy
actually really sweet but we had a good
night and then finally many roads on hot
ones seem to lead back to go into
Glastonbury with Cara Delevingne
do you think that wellington boots are
an underrated fashion statement
they ought do you know what I think Kate
Moss really like made them a fashion
staple she years ago wore them with like
little shorts at Glastonbury and I think
everyone was just like that's the
coolest thing I've ever seen
also it's super muddy at Glastonbury but
yes I would say they're definitely a
fashion staple at Glastonbury pragmatic
and stylish very ready to move on here
mm-hmm
hot tie green in the sixth spot I'm
actually amazed I've made it this far
I'm humbled from the side you're doing
great
that one's really spicy well we'll keep
it moving mm-hmm
so I'm interested in your relationship
your unique relationship with social
media from the point of view of a
business woman in Hollywood how much
stock do you give to the Internet's
ability to swing the success of a film
one way or the other I mean these days
it's huge and it's kind of I mean
closely monitored when people are
putting together a marketing campaign
and strategy of course it's great to
hear what critics thinks but it's not
think about your film but it's also
really great to hear what you know
audiences that's how you make the movie
for so it's good and I think
word-of-mouth can be yeah can I guess
probably kill your film a lot more you
know kind of boost it so yeah if you've
got a good film and people like it it's
really good
- it's actually getting easier I think
cuz now my lips are numb I can't feel
them and my mouth is kind of numbed so
it might be easier at this point all
right and we're approaching this finish
line too
stupid they have to bite them
that's on you mm-hm I don't know
so in addition to acting you're someone
who has a lot of hidden talents a true
renaissance woman from husbandry to
magic to accounting do you have a hack
for how to make a tattoo as painless as
possible is there a way to do that
mmm-hmm be drunk first people aren't
really fazed if they've had a couple
drinks they also don't sit it's still
good so it's good can I take my jacket
off go ahead go ahead
oh my god um I've never eaten anything
so spicy in my life so I'm that would be
my tip just um be drunk beforehand
actually I think they say when you're at
a tattoo shop you can't get a tattoo if
you've had any alcohol
I think it's ins the blood I shouldn't
have said that it's don't
it's the wings talking it's the Winstar
in the lead up to the bigger role in
focus what's the most fascinating thing
you learned from the gentleman thief
Apollo Robbins about the art of
pickpocketing so Apollo Robbins the
gentleman thief taught me how to be a
pickpocket
um but he taught me a little too well
and then we got to set and we'd do the
scene and there'd be like well you were
women to steal the watch I was like I
did and they're like but we didn't see
it happen not like yeah well that's
that's the point that's how he told me
and and so then we had to kind of pivot
the strategy so that we could actually
see the pickpocketing as we went but he
the the interesting things were just
like what your brain actually blocks out
like you could touch someone oh my god
in a particular place
um he said it's like having a spotlight
and you can make someone's brain only
see what you'll shining a spotlight on
you they can do anything else over you
well I would try to take that skill
you've learned mhm and channel it into
this next wig de bomb beyond insanity de
bomb okay
Oh Mughal
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
boom boom so hot ones creator Chris
Schoenberger he grew up watching
neighbors obsessively with his aunt and
money and informs me that it is one of
the goat soap operas of all time and I
was fascinated to learn that the likes
of Russell Crowe Nicole Kidman Kylie
Minogue they've all worked on the show
oh my [ __ ] god what do you think you
learned about acting on a soap that you
wouldn't have learned if you went to
some like prestigious drama school I
[Music]
think I might die um careful around your
eyes um it's so spicy
holy [ __ ] like I don't know how I can
get more spicier than that Oh
oh my god um you have to be WordPerfect
ooh and there's they like this switching
as they as you act so you're hit your
mark or be WordPerfect they and they're
shooting it so quickly then there's
really like no time to mess up and and
and so you just learn an incredible
discipline and you can work really
really fast and um you yeah just a
really conscious of everyone else's jobs
done come on in what is the exit process
on something like that do you have to
give them a certain amount of heads up
so they can write off your character Oh
I did I gave I am I did I I told them
that I was gonna move to America and um
and then I asked if they would kill me
off in a really like a big dramatic way
and they said no because they said well
you know if things don't work out in
America we want you to be able to come
back and play the role again so my
character also moved to America
incidentally I guess she's still left is
back on the show oh my god how are you
okay if you if you're if you're out
you're out and there's no shame in that
Margo it's okay I'm go no no no I don't
wanna be out but I can do one more all
right
salute respect there you know what
rather appropriately this sauce is from
Australia wonderful
[Music]
do not count that it's fine it's fine
it's fine
what does cashed-up bogans mean and can
you use it in a sentence
oh my god that was even so much oh it's
called the Widowmaker fashion um cashed
out Bergen I'm very very happy that you
have heard that saying is that it's a
phrase we actually do use in Australia
Oh bogans kind of like I'm like oh no I
don't know like a chat or you know you
rednecky i guess would be the american
but i don't know but i'm i very much was
a bogan if if you like me when I was
younger when we're out boots out to
dinner thinking that was like going out
to dinner shoes you're probably a bogan
so I was a bogan oh and I cashed out
bogan I said what who has money and so
it spends money on both in things that
are expensive
Dumbledore hero or villain hero my
favorite I feel you I feel you
we are almost to the finish line here
and for wing 10 we have something very
special planned
uh-huh
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] alright here we are at
wing tine it's the season 11 premiere
and we had to do a big so we have all
the birds in the building so let's
welcome to the table Ellijay bosco mary
elizabeth winstead and jurnee smollett
belle where we are going to do a very
special last - shaking it's a tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last one you don't have to if you don't
want to okay
I'd suggest against it yeah this is well
you know she's Korean and Filipino she's
Sheldon face there we go look I am just
a bogan from Australia all right all
right I'm I'm like nervous sighted come
on let's take time in alright good cheer
and cheers thank you ladies for doing
this with me
fire in the hole it's the whole flock
here and when we get everyone at the
table there's only one team-building
exercise we know how to do and that is
the bucket of BFF questions you guys
really good are you serious are you
actually serious it was really good holy
[ __ ] it's the hottest thing I've ever
eaten like six weeks ago it was the
hardest thing I've ever eaten
it was thinking it I'm starting to feel
it oh it's pretty good
that's what it gets in your throat um I
did use it a lot on Wow it went up to my
nose I'm starting it says um which song
of the birds of prey soundtrack best
describes now I'm good my mood at the
wrap party
I mean there's the dinosaur you mix as
Persia captain joke's on you see mr. new
I think this song that best describes
the mood and I have to he's done this
two hundred times really good
bang-bang have taste buds anymore yeah
is it's getting hot in here so now
there's nothing left to do but blast the
AC shut off the cameras and get Margo to
an ice bath but before we do that let's
roll out the red carpet this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life oh
we have a Sun coming out we do we have a
film coming out right in the fantabulous
Emancipation of one Holly Quinn it is in
February 7th it's just that's a
revelation that fixed it like that
that's way better than you should have
had that it's better than skittles oh
yeah I think you guys might be onto
something
oh that's so good hey what's going on
hot ones fans this is Sean Evans
checking in to give you the origin story
behind blows calientes Rojo so a few
months back we decided to go completely
bizarro world and went dr. Frankenstein
on all of our sauces and and started
mixing and matching the peppers and just
put it out thought it would be a stupid
one-time thing but we accidentally threw
that science experiment created one of
the greatest sauces of all time
Louis calientes Rojo get your bottle at
Heat inist
heat nests calm to get a bottle of
Lowe's calientes Rojo lows calientes
Rojo accidentally delicious
[Music]
you